[Music]
foreign
learning today I'm standing in front of
the global headquarter of Allianz
Allianz was kind enough to support the
work of the channel by sponsoring this
video adiance has over 500 consultants
in diverse locations such as the Munich
Singapore Milan Paris and New York in a
moment we are going to meet Vanessa with
a Project Lead here at Allianz
Consulting and today we are going to
learn what the day in the life of a
Project Lead it looks like and what it's
like to work in the in-house consultancy
of such a big multinational Blue Chip
company welcome to alien thanks for
having me very excited for the insights
of the day to kick it off would you like
to introduce yourself and also talk
about your current role here at Allianz
yeah absolutely so my name is Vanessa
and I've been working at Allianz for
about seven years I'm currently in our
in-house consultancy called Allianz
Consulting and I am a Project Lead for
about six Consultants so Heinrich I just
show you what it's all about sounds
great perfect then follow me in thank
you
so I like to start my day here by
checking my emails and my calendar just
to really know what's waiting for me
today and to be able to prioritize my
tasks accordingly makes sense and you
are a Project Lead at Allianz Consulting
can you share what type of project
you're currently working on what type of
topics you're looking into yeah
absolutely so I'm working I'm currently
on a project within customer experience
here in the strategy and marketing
department and what we're more
concretely doing is using real-time
customer feedback in order to identify
Improvement areas along the whole
customer journey and I really love the
project because everything we develop
here is something that touches the End
customer so this is why I'm really
passionate about the topic this sounds
like quite an extensive initiative can
you share what a typical day looks like
a typical schedule looks like maybe the
example of today yeah I mean every day
is of course different but what we
normally do is we start the day with our
daily check-in with the team to really
understand okay where does everyone
stand with all the deliverable levels of
any possible challenges that we might
have and today we'll actually meet the
client for our weekly as well so we
actually have the check-in starting in
just a minute so you can join me and we
can see what the team has for us today
thanks for that exciting perfect so just
all right so there they are hi team how
are you
how's everyone doing everything great
thank you how are you
[Music]
so it seems like we're all aligned for
the client weekly later on so that's
really great team good job so then I
would say let's see each other then in
the meeting and yeah we'll just say
goodbye for now thanks everyone bye bye
guys
all right
I think that was quite interesting it
was also everything happening online I
know that also many people of course
have in their mind when they think about
Consulting what the working hours are
like and also from my own experience I
know that sometimes the hours can be
quite tough can you share a bit more on
what that's like for audience Consulting
yeah sure I think generally it's very
different from day to day
um the normal working hours are around
eight hours there are some days of
course based on the project or the
deliverables that we might work a little
bit longer but there are also many days
where you know it's a little bit more
relaxed and I can actually go home a
little bit earlier so it's quite
flexible that definitely sounds better
than what I was used to and it also had
actually a couple of times also from
other people that in-house Consulting
sometimes are a bit better on this
work-life balance side so let's go to
the client meeting because that's
starting quite soon and then you can
also get a glimpse of what we do there
sounds very interesting thank you
foreign
[Music]
who you met before in our check-in he's
also going to be sitting into the weekly
today how to meet you in person great hi
there in the web access way yeah hi
everyone
all right so have a seat so
then let's get started with the content
I'd say so the agenda for today
um as you know we'll be discussing the
new customer experience initiative and
the launch and I would like to start
with the entities where we don't have
the green light yet to make sure that we
don't fall behind schedule and then
let's continue with the content of the
steer Co next week so that's a very
important topic as well and any open
questions that you might have does that
sound fine for everyone
perfect okay so as for the timeline
Aslam do you have an update so as we
actually discussed earlier today we
still do not have the green light for
the entity so we are currently pending
approval so this is the current status
at the moment and what's causing the
delay we had a change in the management
so we are making a call in the evening
today to align with the entities okay
okay that's good then please let me know
what the outcome is after your call then
this afternoon
and what about for you Oliver from my
end the customer Journey mapping was
completed the stakeholders were very
happy with the results and they're
looking forward to the next steps okay
perfect that sounds great
good so then I think that was all for
the first point so then let's go into
the second point which is the content
for the steer cone next week so I think
Marco you've been working on that
correct
so the details of the speaker were
confidential which is why now stepped
out of the meeting but actually this
weekly format is one that I was quite
familiar with as well so typically you
discuss first the progress of every team
member of the last week or so on the
client side second what the priorities
are for next week and then also any
roadblocks or issues that the team is
facing the team can discuss how to
mitigate that how to address that so
let's now wait for Vanessa until the
meeting is over
right now I'm standing here on the
rooftop Terrace of Allianz in the heart
of Munich big big thanks to Allianz for
supporting the work here on from
learning by sponsoring this video
Alliance Consulting is currently growing
quite rapidly among the locations across
the world so if you are interested in a
new opportunity in in-house Consulting
and strategy Consulting I.T business
operations or any other roads like that
I will link the Liam's career page in
the video description feel free to check
it out I trust there are many
opportunities out there for you to grow
both professionally and personally but
now let's continue with the video
so we're done with the meeting it's all
like great so how has it been I think
about quite well actually the client was
quite happy and we were also able to
align on the content for the steer cone
next week so that was good so for the
uninitiated what exactly is this deal
cold what does that mean yeah so stirco
is short for a steering committee and
this is basically a format that we have
every two three weeks with our project
sponsors normally those are board
members or business unit leaders and
yeah we have the next one coming up next
week as I mentioned so we really were
able to share the slides the first draft
and get everyone's input well it's
indeed a quite common format in
Consulting I mean also what's used to
that quite a bit so yeah I'd say let's
head over to lunch yes let's do it hi
there hi so this is Ricardo and Bola two
other Consultants yes my name is Hanley
so pleasure to meet thanks for allowing
me to join you today pleasure to have
you here yeah so it looks good good
indeed if you don't mind waiting though
what I'd love to do is take the
opportunity to ask you some questions as
well I know that many people in the
audience would be interested on that
maybe let's start just how you got here
got here to Alliance Consulting would
you mind just sharing a very personal
Journey yeah so I came across Alliance
Consulting through a career fair at my
business school and I saw that they were
launching a customer experience practice
which I was really Keen to be a part of
and then I decided to just you know
apply and make an application online and
then the application process started can
you also shed some light into that how
that looks like yeah the first round is
with an engagement manager once you pass
this first round you invited to a
recruiting day the recruiting day
usually um is composed by having
interviews with two partners and one HR
colleague great no that makes sense
sounds like a very typical Consulting
application process
um I think another question that many
people have in their minds when thinking
about Consulting is of course the
Staffing so understood by the diversity
of projects out there hit the lens
converting the what flexibility do you
really have in making your own choices
what topics to pursue can you share
something on this process yes indeed so
I think I ask assaulting we're very
fortunate to have a lot of options and a
lot of different projects to work on
when I joined for instance I was staffed
on a customer experience project because
this is my focus but then I spoke with
my manager that I'm interested in
digital transformation and I really want
to explore that after this I switched
into an m a transaction so really
there's like different options that you
can choose from sounds quite diversity
it understood so at the beginning you're
assigned to a project then of course
over time you can also voice more and
more your preferences exactly makes
sense let's maybe also talk about your
motivation to join Consulting who would
like to share something on that why I
should become a consultant yeah I would
say actually it's very easy this answer
the work-life balance is great
you're working in Consulting combined
with this work-life balance approach and
then you're part of Alliance the
audience group one of the biggest and
largest insurance companies in the world
so all of that three topics like combine
make sure that they wanted to be part of
that word we're working for an
attractive multinational company and
then combining the benefits of being a
consultant with really a solid and
sustainable workout balance definitely
it sounds very relatable definitely
so next why don't we go for a little
walk outside this is something we like
to do a lot
um with our managers or our team members
we walk and talk nice exactly it's a
great way to really take advantage of
the beautiful weather so we're going to
meet Stephan Smith he's the head of
Allianz Consulting
foreign it's a pleasure to meet both of
you now to talk about also your
experiences in Consulting to kick it off
for the audience Stefan mayor ask you to
introduce yourself and your current role
at onions sure thanks honey my name is
Stefan Alexander Schmidt and I'm the
chief sales and custom officer for
Alliance services and head of Allianz
Consulting since four years
I know that many people in the audience
are also quite interested to learn more
about Consulting what is the mission and
vision of Allianz Consulting
the heineck I think we can put this in a
rather short tagline that we came up
four years ago which is Drive change
grow people for Alliance and it's this
free components so we really want to
participate in the big transformational
projects for Allianz that are also
relevant for the insurance industry we
want to invest in our people that they
can grow their capabilities not only
professionally but also personally and
we do that all for Allianz so for
everyone who's not really considering
potentially also applying to Alliance
Consulting what are the things that you
are really looking out for in candidates
when evaluating profiles yeah I mean I
think we always look for people that are
of course motivated but people that are
looking to make a difference and an
impact in the business and one thing
that's really important is that we want
people that are really going to take
their career in their own hands so
there's so many different opportunities
at Allianz Consulting and it's really
what you make out of your career
and talking about opportunities a trust
in a big company like Allianz such a
multinational company there are many
different roads out there what can
candidates expect at Alliance Consulting
what open vacancies are them what areas
I mean if you have the classical roles
ranging from a junior consultant to then
a more managerial role but it's not so
much about the position that people can
can gather the roles I think it's the
environment and the challenges that we
have to offer and this is multiple
different big projects internationally
that are really dealing with the core of
what it is about in changing the
insurance industry to be fit for the
future
and probably that's at least one thing
that's distinctive about a lens
Consulting and this is that for sure
it's an in-house consulting firm so for
everyone who's pondering whether
in-house Consulting is the right choice
as a next step for their career any
insights you can share on that yeah I
mean I think the the really special
thing about it is that your clients are
actually also your colleagues so there's
a lot more collaboration compared to an
external consultancy and one thing that
I like to say a lot is that Alliance
Consulting is really like a small family
or a big family in this case we are very
much connected with one another we share
our knowledge we engage we we are really
helping and supporting each other
because we do have a lot of In-House
knowledge so that's something that I
think Stefan is really special with us
I would just add three things to what
Vanessa said when you start working with
with us you kind of like sign two
contracts one for Consulting and one for
the group because you immediately start
building both careers distinctively for
for Consulting and then also you build
your reputation in the group the second
thing is it's a truly International
environment so we have more than 70
nationalities the projects are really in
an international context if you sign
with other external companies you should
work in the markets with people from the
market and last but not least
we always have skin in the game for
aliens
[Music]
30 minute break now until my next
meeting so I'm thinking of heading home
and working from there for the rest of
the day and because I have football
training later on so I want to make sure
that I'm there on time so do you want to
maybe join me on mine I have some good
coffee as well thanks for the invitation
I love coffee let's do it perfect
[Music]
foreign
it is and I had promised you some coffee
yeah so I could see that now the last
hours he worked here from your apartment
how is this all work from home thing
working out for you it's working out
great I must say I really enjoy the
flexibility that I have between working
from home or from the office or really
do both like we did today so this is
something that I really appreciate and I
also really appreciate all the different
kind of offerings that Alliance
Consulting has for us what other
offerings are there out there well I
mean Alliance Consulting has been great
in really showing their support and that
they care for the employees so they
really made sure to come up with a bunch
of offerings around mental health
physical health and these are yeah
offerings that I also take advantage of
regarding physical activities and at the
moment we also have the football
practice right yes we do
and we still have a bit of time so we
can finish our coffee and then I'll get
changed and we can head out together
sounds like a plan
[Music]
yeah so I mean when I'm not at work you
can pretty much find me here I actually
started the first women's football team
at Allianz about five years ago and we
play in the Barbarian Football League
trying twice a week and pretty much play
games every single weekend you're quite
serious yeah we try to be at least it
was
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for allowing me to
follow you here throughout the day I
also myself got some good learnings from
that and I hope that for everyone in the
audience there are some good insights on
in-house Consulting on Alliance
Consulting as well thank you my pleasure
Heinrich I hope you had fun because I
definitely did absolutely
big thanks to Allianz for supporting the
work on the channel and sponsoring this
video if you have any questions at all
about what it's like to work in
consulting or at Alliance please feel
free to leave a comment in the comment
section if you're looking for new career
opportunities I will leave a link to the
careers page of alliance in the video
description as always if you took any
value at all out of this video please
destroy the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and also subscribe to the
channel big big thanks to all the
members of the channel as well my name
is Heinrich always weekly videos here on
the channel see you again next week and
bye bye